une opération expérimentale a été lancée
afin de procéder à des essais de balle
et ergonomique et de produits de
nettoyage biotechnologiques pour les
agents d'entretien du conseil général
les agents ont participé à une formation
afin de découvrir le nouveau matériel
l'objectif proposer des accessoires plus
pratique et non chimiques afin de
satisfaire les utilisateurs
alors contrairement aux autres ballets
il était étudiée pour limiter au maximum
tout ce qui était fait mais c'est à dire
troubles musculo squelettiques donc
c'est un ballet qui va s'adapter à la
taille de chacun des utilisateurs parce
qu'ils étaient les scopique c'est un
ballet qui est extrêmement léger qui a
une rotule ici grippe qui va permettre
de limiter les mouvements en force du
poignet parce que le poignet est
toujours mobile grâce à la à la rotule
qui qui tombe dans tous les sens il
permet aussi de faire du nettoyage en
vertical et au plafond parce que il ya
une
une rotule ici qui est multi
directionnelle et quand on veut faire du
nettoyage ou plafond il suffit de
bloquer ici la rotule et on a à ce
moment là un nettoyage qui va être
facilitée d'avant en arrière
les modes microfibre ont une texture
avec une tribu un triple tissage qui va
permettre une action mécanique renforcer
donc l'action mécanique des agents ils
vont plus être obligé de forcer sur le
sur le ballet pour pour le nettoyer pour
nettoyer pour avoir un résultat de
nettoyage plus intéressant et surtout
l'après là les propriétés mécaniques de
la microfibre vont retenir les
salissures et éviter le recherche
relâche âge articulaire au niveau du sol
donc les à lisieux reste prisonnière
dans la microfibre
il est entièrement démontable les toutes
les pièces sont peuvent être changées y
compris les velcros qui se trouvent ici
qui est qu'ils vont pouvoir être
nettoyés quand qu'il va y avoir un petit
peu de saleté dedans au niveau des
produits on est là aussi sur quelque
chose qui permet de limiter au maximum
la chimie cirque on est sur des produits
enzymatiques donc c'est des bactéries
qui vont se nourrir des salissures et
les rendre soluble dans l'eau donc on a
zéro impact sur l'environnement et zéro
impact néfaste au niveau des agents qui
vont utiliser ces produits
y'a pas de problème au niveau
respiratoire il ya pas de problème au
niveau des yeux
évidemment si on se met du produit dans
les yeux il va falloir le rincer mais en
tous les cas pas d'effet nocif ou
d'effets secondaires indésirables
une formation qui a déjà su convaincre
et le futur utilisateur qui vend ses
produits une amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail
le bal est superbe et au quotidien plus
de peut-être rapidité en fonction de ma
grande
et pratique ergonomique très bien pour
la grandeur léger léger y passe dans
tous les coins c'est vraiment ce sera
vraiment tout
il y aura déjà moins de produits on
n'utilisera plus la ja bell et puis bon
mais sera vraiment très bien pour
l'environnement
quand on regarde le produit c'est vrai
que ça a l'air d'être efficace puisque
le bal est réglable comme on a vu les
agents ont pu à se baisser pour ramasser
la serpillière les produits sont
écologiques
ce qui veut dire qu'il y aura moins
c'est moins nocif pour les agents par
rapport aux produits qu'on utilise
actuellement et je pense que quand même
maison - moins d'efforts à faire et ils
ont moins mal surtout autour
en utilisant ce produit après avoir
testé les produits les agents rempliront
une fiche d'évaluation afin de savoir si
les produits sont efficaces et
améliorent leur tâche